ja gut aber ob das dann wirklich machst
ja da bin ich dumm ich springe auf seine
lampe hallo meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu minecraft
epic balance zwischen zusammenkommen hdh
habe einen checkpoint angeblich aber ich
glaube nicht dass es ein check dann
machst du mal machte mal der das ist nur
für dich gedacht der checkpoint sich
auch der garten blocking gesetzt wie die
denker ein regelverstoß und ich bin
gespannt
hast du gedrückt ich hab's gedrückt okay
in check point war das wirklich super
ich habe direkt vor guck mal über uns
fit habe ich mich erschreckt wurde in
russland wurde ein alter dass es wegen
dem bachelor gibt deswegen ist der
unsichtbare ach ja stimmt ja bedrock war
ja hier von der textur her unsichtbar
sieht alles auch wieder schön gemacht
wird man richtig hier so ein
schreckmoment mit eingebaut war bestimmt
immer wenn er sich die folgen anguckt na
gut nicht vielleicht von uns obwohl er
ja bei dir öfters mal kommentar
geschrieben hat wie gefährlich das
passiert oft dass der kommentar in
seiner frau unter der folge geschrieben
ja hat er gemacht ich hab die kommentare
was ihr gelesen und da hat er wirklich
und hat eine video ist geborsten
warum spielt die karte den kopf doch mal
auf meinen kanal ich hab noch andere
trailer und so weiter hat er gekostet
bei dir unter sich und ist das nicht ein
amerikaner hat auch amerikanische
positiv
ja finde ich auch cooler typ euch gar
nicht gesehen so habe ich mich super
schnitzel drin gelassen der wo bleibst
du eigentlich ich komme ja auch direkt
muss übrigens ganz nach vorne drücken du
musst ihren kommen jetzt muss wieder
runter verstehe ja klar immer doch ich
kenne das mittlerweile schon geil lecker
gut durchgebraten oder nicht
doch schon länger ok medium anscheinend
ja medium so ganz durch medium
kanaltechnik ja so sie springen ja auch
noch meistern
nein von einem durch ein richtiger beim
einer folge auch ebenso da bin ich auch
am ende gab es noch den allerletzten
warte ich konnte mich ganz kurz dir auch
das ok bin da so hält alter wollte
gerade gar nix
nein also warte okay aber ich geschafft
ich bin hinter dir
die sprünge schaffen wir auf jeden fall
und den auch den auch den auch in einem
speed run hierdurch letzte schaffst du
nicht geschafft dort er ist ein bild
verschafft aber da kann man durchgehen
und noch von einer anderen seite sieht
das bild wird sich aus hast du dir genau
angeguckt man ganz alleine wieder rein
ins boot und ab
[Musik]
alle sind monster oder irgendwie sowas
wie wow das ist echt toll dass eine
echte grippe
[Musik]
die können nicht springen stimmt werden
auch gut sein
ich habe es geschafft durch meike komme
komme gleich bus nicht ganz das habe ich
ja auch nicht von leichter boss
eigentlich abgewandelt das neue schon
also like the boss abmontieren
es kommt von was ist von 3com
abgewandelt auch so um fallstein weit
gekommen steht eigentlich immer eher für
fällen also also eigentlich das
gegenteil von bord das ist der boss im
seinen mantel und da pumpt die eisernen
hand eine regulierte szene
alleine die ganzen rappers in china ok
hallo bitte sperren das video natürlich
nehme jedoch nicht ich habe mir schon
wieder besser auf und ich habe guckt
schicken aber noch keine punkte ok in
puncto du ja ich habe zwei was ja ich
habe dir doch mal wieder aufgesammelt
und ich nähere mich mal dabei
hallo ich komme den er freundin gleich
da nenne ich sie mitbekommen dass ich
das ich gestorben bin oder habe ich
mitbekommen
aber ich sag nur noch auf meine freundin
ihr fokussiert gertrud ich komme hier
endlich die erste mal schwimmst du immer
noch fressen ja leider manchmal aufholen
[Musik]
schauen dass ich die chance dort
anzuziehen
ja gut aber ob das dann wirklich machst
also wenn ich dumm ich bin auch so eine
lampe jump in vila vita nicht ja ja ja
schön bruno mars okay das ist jetzt das
normale wolken hatte die cd to go wir
sind ja auch extra ins haus and we try
again at michael world okay ich will
auch auf die lande gesprungen aber
wieder zurück also ich hab mein chef
kommt übrigens nicht so cool wie ein
eisblock vor checkpoint bekenne ich
warte jetzt erst mal auf dich da kommt
dann daraus nicht lesen habe ich glaub
schon von jeher ich bin schon ein
bisschen weiter
ich bin ja auch gleich da warten uhr war
so leid gekommen ist einfach weggeputzt
und gleich gekommen ist einfach wie
leichte fehler
das ist so der unterschied auf kalorien
gleichgekommen gesagt hat sich einfach
dumm anhört
maike komme ja wohl gerade runter
gefallen ja dann würde ich mal sagen
gleichgekommen gekommen und ich schaffe
gerade alles in einem durchlauf leid
gekommen
vielleicht bekommt und weitermachen
weitermachen hier überspringen den
letzten sprung schaffst du nicht
ladylike konny reimann ich habe es
geschafft hätte kann ihren 1000 us
majors soll das heißt es wird schwer sie
zu erreichen
[Musik]
gertrud
also da war ja nur eine wurst drin aber
schon mal gut anfangen da sowieso unten
womit ihr wollt das vorbild an ich weiß
jetzt schon gesehen ich war nicht im
bilde war genau die kleinigkeiten die
mag ich an der karte die macht keine
einhell marica ein extra im texture pack
nur für die karte und dann genau dass
solche bilder noch mit einbau und ich
liebe diese ganzen bilder extra für die
map zu gemacht das ist sehr schön
das sind übrigens haben wie zum beispiel
warum gespannt und meine sich gerade mit
lockenkopf gespannt und mit
wie sehen denn die aus man warte das
einfach weiterlaufen da die macht eine
menge schaden
nein haut ab haut ab
ich habe es geschafft die kommt nicht
rüber einmal weiter springen kommen
glaub an dich ich glaube nicht ja ich
habe jetzt zum glück den goldenen apfel
noch gehabt ohne den dänen wäre ich
schon lange tot
wenn du weiter läuft die wendeltreppe
ist nicht dafür da dass du sie runter
geht sondern einfach so als check polen
wenn du wieder hochkommen will ok chef
sollte auch immer versuchen bei solchen
sachen die dann so direkt in einen
marsch durch zu schaffen
ich habe es geschafft gut dann da gerade
aus weiter machen halten mit dem blick
nach vorne gerichtet und nicht wenn ich
hier richtig überhaupt ja bist du gut
ich rate dir nur nach jedem sprung
wirklich einzeln ich habe es geschafft
kommt das schaffst du und jawohl haye
weiter machen dann könnte läuft richtig
gut hier gerade unter gpl und und ich
glaube dass trainierte gerade die ist
wirklich gerade richtig gut kann man das
trainiert uns doch alles so ein bisschen
diese ganzen maps jumpen okay aber ab
die hier wirklich trainiert ich weiß es
nicht mehr so in den fingerfertigkeit
die geht ja eigentlich noch von den
schritt mit drin
und du in mir das viel zu fett müssen
wir so aufdringlich pro 100 man jetzt
geschafft wirklich hätte das auch auf
jeden fall geschafft hatte mal wieder in
die kommentare schreiben komme ich immer
nur die leute mich ja ich bin ja aus her
okay jetzt auch mal hier sind alle mann
würdigen kritischen kräfte ist schlau
danke scheiße ich wollte sich eigentlich
vor dessen hatte ich geglaubt und die
verbindung gerade die verbindung hat ist
richtig geil andere an der raumstation
einer raumstation und das hast du glaub
ich oder gerade gut nachdem mein
computer abgestürzt ist kann ich traue
ich mir eigentlich wirklich alles hierzu
vor allem ein ganz neuer computer der
ach was so warte hier in das
wasserbecken man ich hoffe die ganze
zeit da bin ich jetzt so schnell wenn
das ist eine kiste krieges stattdessen
vielleicht haben wir unter alter wie
komme ich jetzt hoch gar nicht mehr
jedoch da ein bisschen dran ist verloren
offiziell ist eine leiter altern ich
muss jetzt wieder ordnung komme bei dir
und ich habe es geschafft
familie klein ich okay so ich bin auf
dem weg und ein lava sprüngen gepasst
auf nein nein aber ich habe es geschafft
das war richtig gab und die sprünge hier
nochmal machen alles ja warte ich muss
was hier gerade noch mal machen aber ich
habe es geschafft
ja ich bin auf dem weg bin und da möchte
ich nur mal eben eine kiste abstauben
[Musik]
fast auf die lage auf dem weg hin und
weg das sagen sie alle ok geschafft ich
höre hier irgendwo monster lux verlieren
okay da oben ist ein knopf hier komme
ich nicht weiter an ein bisschen ich bin
ich halt rennen ja geschafft hat einfach
genau gepasst auf meine sache gerade
auch ich springe darüber nicht verbrennt
verbrennt nicht verbrennen und sich vor
den apotheken und soja passt als herzog
hat meine sicht gesehen so bin bei dir
müssen wir da rein
hierüber ich habe schon davon geguckt da
vorankommen keine kiste mehr also in dem
raum hier
ich habe hier schon ausführlich alle
studiert die wege kann ich exakt ich
weiß genau wie ich laufen muss schade
aber ich hab's geschafft
ja gut das habe ich auch geschafft aber
das probieren einmal hoch und dann der
blüte sprung dann schaffe ich nie okay
ich hab s geschafft
ich habe auch direkt
ich glaube jetzt ist bei mir so eine
phase mich dann einfach nicht stoppen
egal was ich mache es gab einfach alles
genau so wie beim fc bayern münchen zu
zeigt egal was wir brauchen einfach
alles ach ist das schön du das
einsteigen bitte und ab die fahrt ob der
fisch ja ich dachte schon ich falle in
eine lage und ein lama becken rein
ich dachte ich mir einfach nur total
attacken und schaffe und habe wieder
etwas falsch gebracht so darf man wir
springen dann hier hoch und soll so ein
troll anne welche ich liebe diese diesem
typ mir einfach wie kommt man auf solche
ganzen ideen und davon war noch eine tür
so ergeht wie man darunter an die tür
nee du gehst herunter nee du ja ok nein
macht es einfach
das kann gar nicht klappen weil hier
wenn wir beide hier stehen das kann gar
nicht funktionieren was mich in einer
band die sich das so nein du bist doch
nicht passt auf ok ich meine hause ich
gehe dabei für kunden und du das kann
man gar nicht schaffen glaube ich jeder
tür da kann man gar nicht reinkommen
damit wollte uns glaube ich nur wer
fertig machen dann kann man gar nicht
rein
ja ich glaube man muss das ding auch gar
nicht klappen muss das nur so in wir
machen ja so muss man das machen
[Musik]
wie hoch wir warten mal ganz kurz zu
jetzt hier drauf hat und die auch noch
ausgesagt am besten da hoch dann der
arbeiter genau ok geschafft dass eine
kiste mit brot weil ich einfach die
punkte ja ich auch nicht ich habe null
punkten
die k aber ich würde sagen die nächsten
folge bei kommen da hatte ich mich noch
ganz gut jetzt wieder back to lend
kommen wir schlaf noch mal eine runde
und beenden damit dann auch die folge
bei dir hier in solche gefallen hat der
nächste titel einer bewertung da lassen
und wir sehen uns dann einfach morgen in
der nächsten folge beim hd auf dem kanal
bis zum nächsten mal reinschauen